[Music]
it's been a rough 24 hours for Justin
Bieber but you know what good news he
could smile today because his despedido
collaboration is officially spent 16
weeks at number one on the Billboard Hot
100 chart time Mariah Carey and Boyce
the men's one sweet Michelle Turner has
danced her way into position just enough
the only one breaking records today
no no Katy Perry Kim Kardashian Kanye
way I mean there's a bunch of people
very good boy listen to the video with
the biggest debut of any video in
youtube history listen to this forty
three point two million views in only 24
hours but is it the best clap back song
of all time let's break down music's
best diss track you're not gonna see us
complainin we're havin a good time with
the demise of his three-year
relationship with Britney came the most
iconic song of Justin's career 2002 s
Crimea river from the silhouette of the
spears look-alike to putting alleged
infidelity on blast Justin left little
for interpretation despite never
actually admitting publicly who the song
is about
when Stefani wrote her 2005 hit holla
back girl after Courtney Love was quoted
as saying being famous is just like
being in high school but I'm not
interested in being the cheerleader I'm
not interested in being Gwen Stefani
well win flip the script with an
infectious high school style chant
giving her the last word VMAs Vanguard
winner pink unleashed a huge rebel yell
with her 2006 Grammy nominated hit
stupid girls cheap parody boats Jessica
Simpson's these boots are made for
walking video and Paris Hilton sex tape
the message well it's pretty
straightforward
it's open for your own interpretation
that's what I like to do with songs and
in 2009 Mariah denied rapper Eminem's
claim to the hook-up in the most epic of
ways
[Music]
obsessed featured an Eminem doppelganger
who's actually Mariah and Mimi leaves
him brokenhearted in front of her shrine
it could be a battle every was obsessed
with me I don't know Alanis Morissette
you ought to know iconic and if you
being honest the best diss tracks come
from the world of hip-hop in my opinion
the best ever
no Vaseline from Ice Cube
[Music]
you